still traumatized by game of thrones red
wedding look away now to avoid the
spoilers because house of the dragon now
has a deadly wedding of its own though
george rr martin wrote the red wedding
decades before it aired on hbo longtime
fans and newcomers alike were shocked
when during the third season of game of
thrones a gruesome slaughter took place
at what was supposed to be a joyful
occasion from that moment on the red
wedding became one of the most infamous
scenes not just on game of thrones but
in television history now the prequel
and spin-off to game of thrones which
focuses on the targaryen family and its
civil war for the iron throne has a
bloody wedding of its own after king
viserys aligns the house of targaryen
with the esteemed house valarian by
betrothing his daughter and named heir
rhaenyra to lane or velaryon everyone
seems pleased enough so viserys throws
an entirely over-the-top wedding to
celebrate the union in true westerosi
fashion though this wedding doesn't
exactly go as planned during the pilot
of game of thrones targaryen descendant
daenerys targaryen is told a dothraki
wedding without at least three deaths is
considered a dull affair apparently her
ancestors adopted some dothraki customs
themselves or at least their guests did
after being confronted by lanor's secret
lover sir joffrey lonmuth rhaenyra's own
secret lover sir kristen cole savagely
beats the other knight to death
pummeling him until he doesn't have a
face anymore the ensuing brawl among the
guests definitely has some serious red
wedding energy though it's not quite as
pointed as the red wedding it's still a
joyful ceremony gone horribly wrong to
make matters worse viserys ends up
collapsing as soon as rhaenyra and
lenore are officially married his fate
isn't currently certain but it's not
likely to help the fragile state of the
kingdom in case you forgot what actually
happened during the red wedding here's a
refresher in the wake of ned stark's
execution at the hands of sadistic
incest baby king joffrey baratheon king
in the north rob stark marches south for
vengeance in order to build his army and
secure passage across a crucial river
rob enters into a strategic marriage
though he's promised to one of the many
many daughters of important ally walder
frey rob strays off the path set for him
by his mother and marries to lisa with
whom he has fallen in love walder frey
puts on a brave face about the whole
thing and accepts ed mertoli for one of
his daughters instead secretly though he
aligns himself with the lannisters and
boltons and plans to wipe out the starks
as edmure and his bride are taken to
their wedding bed walter frey locks the
doors behind rob catlin and talisa
they're all brutally killed soon after
the lannisters and their records
the scene and house of the dragon isn't
quite as dramatically bloody as the red
wedding but there's a distinct
similarity that can't be overlooked just
as walder frey settles for edmure lord
corliss velaryon and his wife reynise
originally want to marry their daughter
to viserys but settle for their son
becoming king consort to the presumed
future queen instead clearly bad things
happen when people don't get their first
choice